[Musique]
sont assez vides il y a de rares
magasins ouverts la nuit tombe très tôt
vers 16h on se retrouve vite dans le
noir complet la mer nous a également
confié que tout était fait pour effacer
les traces du passage des Russes dans
les dans les écoles dans les magasins le
rouble était en circulation les médias
les gens par l'Ukrainien et ne veulent
surtout plus parler russe partout dans
la ville vous pouvez voir des panneaux
publicitaires sur lesquels on peut lire
personne citer des héros chers
compatriotes ça y est vous êtes enfin
libre et il y a aussi des panneaux
publicitaires sur lesquels vous pouvez
lire envoyez-nous des informations sur
les traîtres il y a un QR code que vous
pouvez flasher pour donner des
informations aux autorités locales de
personnes ont encore été arrêtées mardi
la mère nous a expliqué que des
investigations étaient en cours que la
police chercher les traits mais aussi
des soldats russes qui sont restés dans
la ville et qui sont sans doute habillés
en civil et sont traqués tous ceux qui
seront arrêtés seront traduits en
justice merci beaucoup Pauline pour
toutes vos précisions depuis